this is Dirk twine and I'll be speaking
with Dr Joel Wallach the mineral doctor
Dr Wallach is considered the premier
Authority on nutrition in the United
States he has written more than a dozen
books on health and nutrition and
countless peer-reviewed papers one of
his earliest books exposed the
consequences of nutritional deficiencies
in animals and humans entitled diseases
of exotic animals and is currently in
the U.S Smithsonian Institute and has
been declared a National Treasure Dr
wallach's research and discovery of the
90th Century nutrients required for
animals and humans was groundbreaking in
the fact that 60 of the 90 nutrients or
minerals has garnered Dr Wallach the
title of the mineral doctor
foreign
[Music]
speaking with Dr Joel Wallach the
mineral doctor Dr Wallach and I will
discuss the vegetarian diet however
before we begin the discussion I would
like Dr Wallach to briefly share with us
some of the more than 40 Years of
biomedical research and clinical
medicine experience that he has in
nutrition and in health well thank you
Dirk the thing that makes me different
when it comes to being a health
practitioner is that I have a degree in
agriculture in the agricultural industry
we don't have health insurance for
animals so we learned how to prevent
reverse diseases with nutritional
formulas we've known for over a hundred
years that our food supply for livestock
and humans is deficient so we do have to
make up that differ went on to get a
degree in veterinary medicine and then I
became a compare pathologist in one
project with the National Institute to
held the centers for the biology of
natural systems Washington University of
St Louis I actually did over 20 000
autopsies from zoos and human beings
living near the zoo some 17 500 autops
season over 454 species of zoo animals
and three thousand humans for comparison
10 million chemistries 10 million slides
of special stains looking for pollution
primarily but also looking for
nutritional deficiencies and actually
published the first paper ever in the
United States on a mass die off from
pollution in 1962 and that just to
actually set my career off in the
particular direction that I wound up
with one paper then went to as I say
graduated veterans then became a
physician and treating patients as a
primary care physician in 1978 and so
I've got 35 years of experience in
translating animal nutrition into human
nutrition of course a lot of my patients
would have a lot of fun with it and they
say well if you're not happy with your
doctor or go see Wallach now he'll treat
you like a dog which you get better oh
that's great well thank you doc as a
vegetarian for nearly 20 years I'm very
eager to hear your perspective on
vegetarianism so so let's get started
firstly I'd like to share something that
probably most people are unaware of uh
the word vegetarian comes from the Latin
word vegetas which means whole energetic
and full of life it was coined in the
1840s in England so this that phrase has
been been around for quite some time
however in the U.S today it has a
slightly different meeting it seems to
have expanded since the Inception of the
philosophy and the practice let's look
at the various types of vegetarians in
the U.S first we'll start out with vegan
spelled v-e-g-a-n but pronounced vegan a
person that eats a plant-based diet
exclusively fruits vegetables nuts
grains seeds legomes or beans a lacto is
a person that eats a plant-based diet
but also includes dairy products such as
cow's milk and its byproducts cheese
yogurt sour cream
Etc oval is a person that eats a
plant-based diet also but includes eggs
from either chickens or duck or some
other type of animal Pesco is a person
that eats a plant-based diet but
includes fish and then Polo is a person
that eats the plant-based diet and also
includes use chicken however the only
true vegetarian is the vegan and all
others are consuming animal flesh hence
nutritionally they are nearly the same
therefore our discussion will primarily
be about the vegan vegetarian diet I
think we will try to express the
challenges of that type of diet so doc
let's begin with the most frequently
Asked question of vegetarians can the
vegetarian diet meet all nutritional
needs particularly protein in modern
times the answer to that is no and I'm
always sad when people pay primarily
attention to protein as a vegan's mantra
oh we mix legumes and Grains together so
we get perfect protein well that's only
one of the 90 essential nutrients
they're leaving themselves under the
other 89 is that leaving out of the
other 89 to get vegans in trouble you
think about some of the more famous
vegans Linda McCartney Paul McCartney
the beetle his wife actually made more
money selling her prepared vegan meals
or and her vegan cookbook she made more
money she made billions of dollars as
opposed to The Beatles She made more
money than they did as a singing group
and she died of 52. then you look at
Michael Jackson whose life was really
messed up and he was a vegan hey look at
um Steve Jobs he was a vegan he died of
56 and so on and so veganism is
problematic and the reason is the
Assumption when you eat a vegan diet is
that everything is perfect and it's not
uh what you're doing is you're depending
on getting the all 90 essential
nutrients on the throw of a dice every
morning what if I were to prepare a game
for you Dirk and say okay let's let's
play a game let's both we're going to
agree the rest of our lives are going to
play this game you wake up in the
morning and you throw the dice and if
you get any number of Snake Eyes which
is a one on both dice you get to live
another day but if you get Snake Eyes
you shoot yourself in the head that's
not a good game yeah it's not a good
game because eventually you're going to
get snake eyes aren't you that's what
even though he said well I mean come on
how often is that going to happen but
you're gonna wind up shooting yourself
in the head if you follow the rules of
the game the same with veganism there
are some communities around the world
who can practice veganism because of
dumb luck because they've got 60 70
minerals in their soil and all the
nutrients they grow in the soil all the
plants they grow in the soil will suck
up these minerals they use wood for fuel
their third world cultures they use wood
for fuel and they're putting the wood
ashes which really aren't ashes which
are the the minerals are left when you
burn the tree for fuel they put that in
the garden and the trees take up those
minerals which are recycling those 60
essential minerals we're talking about
really isolated places very few out of 7
billion people on Earth were talking
about maybe 200 people okay less than
four or less than one percent obviously
you know one thousandths of one percent
could eat well and get everything they
need and so we actually began to shoot
ourselves in fact the guy who invented
McCormick farming equipment he died in
his 30s from pernicious anemia because
he was a vegan I mean he was one of the
first billionaires in America along with
the steel makers you know Carnegie and
people like that and his name was
McCormick and he died of pernicious
anemia actually took a tour of the
facility they're his original plan and
they said he died of pernicious anemia
and I said well that's just a B12
deficiency and they said well yeah you
got to be 12 deficiency because he was a
vegan okay okay uh I always that was a
great uh analogy that you gave but I
like to uh when I speak to people about
supplementing I like to give a car
analogy if I was leaving Atlanta Georgia
going to California and my fuel gauge
didn't work I would certainly fill up my
car on a daily basis to make sure that I
had enough fuel to make it across the
country and I think that's analogous to
what you're saying in terms of we can't
take the chance on winning out of gas we
have to fuel ourselves on a daily basis
and my understanding and uh correct me
if you you may uh that the main reason
that we're eating food on a daily basis
is to get nutrients from that food we're
not eating for Taste we're not eating
because it's pretty we're eating because
our body requires nutrients well you're
exactly right these 90 essential
nutrients have that funny little word in
there essential isn't out the 90
optional nutrients they're as
predictable as gravity you will die if
you're missing these things some of them
like a potassium if you don't have any
potassium in your diet your heart will
stop and you'll die within seconds after
being totally deficient in potassium on
the other hand if you're deficient in
calcium you might live 40 years but
you're going to have osteoporosis you'll
get fractures you get kidney stones your
teeth will fall out you get high blood
pressure you get bone spurs and calcium
deposits you'll mind with all these
weird diseases which support the
orthopedic surgeons very well thank you
um your urologists for kidney stones and
dentists for periodontal disease all of
which are simple Calcium deficiency
diseases but eventually you'll fall in
fracture a hip and so secondary is a
secondary cause of the Calcium
deficiency will die and so
um every one of these essential
nutrients is required every day in
optimal amounts and I'm I'm 73 now Dirk
and I've been taking these 90 essential
nutrients twice a day since I was nine
years old this has nine and I've been
blessed with good health haven't been to
a doctor with me being the patient in 64
years and um I've never been on a
prescription medication and this is
because I have gone out of my way to
supplement my food and I eat well I eat
very well because again I have a degree
in agriculture I'm a veterinarian I'm a
physician I'm a pathologist and so I
know you have to eat well and I eat well
but I don't depend on the nutrients in
the food I just look at nutrients in the
food as value added and to me eating is
more of a social event because I
supplement twice a day with a 90
essential nutrients I take in probably
in some cases 25 000 times the minimum
day requirement you heard that number
right 25
000.25 000 times the minimum data
requirement okay and people say well how
do you keep going how can you do 300
free lectures a year and and you're
never worn out you're never angry you're
never depressed I said well it's because
they take the 90 essential nutrients
twice a day but I don't take them I
don't minimize I don't take them at the
minimum daily requirement okay for
instance selenium the minimum data
requirement according to the government
is 60 micrograms a day it prevents heart
disease dementia things like Ms
cataracts and prevents liver cirrhosis
prevents cardio cardiomyopathy heart
disease prevents cancer prevents certain
types of anemia prevents certain types
of vascular disease certain types of
arthritis certainly can some types of
thyroid problems are all due to a sodium
deficiency and so am I going to risk you
know eating just well and hoping it's in
there's just like Brazil nuts there is a
myth out there that you can eat three
Brazil nuts a day and get all the
salinity Brazil nuts don't require
selenia right okay now if that Brazil
nut tree was grown and so rich and
selenium it'll have some selenium in
there you can't tell by looking at that
Brazil nut to see if there's any in
there because it doesn't require it on
the other hand if you look at a tree or
a tomato plant that requires magnesium
to make the green leaves and the
chlorophyll so they can use the sun's
energy for growth and production of
whatever it is it's producing seeds for
the Next Generation if it doesn't have
magnesium it the leaves turn yellow once
you see brown or yellow leaves on a
plant you know there's not enough
magnesium in there so if there's a
minimum magnesium the the plant will
pump that magnesium from the lower
leaves into the growth leaves at the top
and so that's why the the growth leaves
are the top are always raining the lower
leaves are the ones that turn brown
because the plants are stealing from the
lower leaves to give to the growth
leaves and so the same thing is true for
us you get diseases when you're
deficient in these nutrients plants only
need three magnesium phosphorus
potassium so if you're eating a pretty
good slice of organically grown
multigrain bread baked With Love by the
pastor's wife who's a vegan you're 57
short absolutely let's look back at what
you just mentioned about the calcium
back up to the calcium and continue with
the protein piece it's said that protein
consumption causes calcium loss let's
talk about that a little bit well that's
true because protein always has
phosphorus associated with it and the
more phosphorus you increase in your
diet the more calcium you need to be
taking in a ratio of two calcium atoms
per one atom of phosphorus we're eating
lots of proteins you're getting lots of
phosphorus lots of phosphates and that
increases your your amount of calcium
you have let's say you take in 100 grams
of phosphorus a day in a pound of meat
well that means you need four pounds of
meat if there's calcium in it or at
least the equivalent of four times that
much calcium to make it right okay and
so if you if you look at my book rare
earth wind cures in chapter 11 under
calcium I show you the different types
of Fuji and the common average amounts
of phosphorus and calcium in them and
how much you have to supplement to make
up that difference well in the animal
industry we've spent a hundred billion
dollars figuring that out just for
calcium dirt okay 100 billion dollars
and so when you look at a guinea pig
pellet you know a little Alfalfa pellet
for guinea pigs rabbit pellet chicken
pellet duck pellet turkey pellet Mouse
pellet
um you have Kibbles and Bits dog food
we've perfected it and anything that's
in that dog food or rabbit food or
guinea pig food or rat food or Mouse
food or chicken food anything that's
actually in the food from a nutritional
standpoint whether it's protein or
whether it's minerals or vitamins is
value added we do not depend on it or
the vegan because they're eating well it
tastes good looks good to the eye eating
well you know fits their philosophy uh
they're going to get nailed just on a
dumb chance out of just dumb chance uh
it's impossible to get everything you
need just by eating well and so they
will get them eventually yeah so let's
look at uh the the vegetarian philosophy
in terms of there's certain Nutri
certain foods that supposedly provides
with lots of calcium things like green
leafy vegetables soy sea vegetables
molasses and almonds and figs are all
supposedly great sources of calcium what
would you say to a vegetarian that's
trying to eat that way I would still
supplement with calcium and you got from
those fruits and vegetables I would look
at that as value added I can't stress
that enough that you know human beings
are supposedly at the top end of the
intelligence ranking compared to other
animals other vertebrates and you can
supplement we actually have supplement
programs vegans use there's no animal
products in there and it's insane why
would you throw away 50 years of your
life because you don't want a supplement
to prove a point it's impossible it's
impossible even these cultures that live
in the world that some RV and they do
eat vegan diet because they're poor they
don't have lands to graze animals and
have animals they don't live near a sea
or they can get fish and just by
necessity or just by bad luck or where
they chose to live or where they were
driven by their enemies they learned to
exist on a vegan diet well many many
peoples and animals have disappeared you
know the species that didn't make it or
the cultures that didn't make it they
disappeared but by dumb luck by just
dumb luck Dirk there's the top 20
cultures on Earth the top longevity
cultures on Earth they live in places
that have more than 16 minerals or so
and they burn the wood for fuel for
cooking and heating they put those
minerals those AKA wood ashes into their
Gardens their tomatoes and sweet
potatoes and beets and rice and whatever
it is they're growing fruit trees and
and so forth onions suck all those 60 70
minerals up that's what makes us
different our mineral Source our plant
minerals are based in different plants
it's an ancient compost pile contains 77
minerals including all 60 essential
minerals so we're different in that we
provide and guarantee all 60 essential
minerals where nobody else can do that
and so it makes this different you look
at baby food this is very scary this
just came out in in April of 2012. baby
foods that we entrusted our babies to
over the years Similac Enfamil Gerbers
have 13 or less minerals in it now we
need 60. you take a baby and you feed
them a baby formula well the 13 minerals
in it how many minerals are in there 13
13. what about the other 47. baby
doesn't have you wonder why the baby's
chewed up well the babies are screwed up
mentally and physically not because of
vaccinations now vaccinations there are
kids who are terribly damaged by
vaccinations but we're looking at three
out of a thousand terrible damage and
you know I wouldn't vaccinate kids
except for when there's a plague going
through there and ten thousand people
are dying an hour then you want to take
your chances and get that vaccination
right that risk is worth it when
everything is going well and people are
practicing good hygiene Plumbing is
working and and you're eating well
you're supplementing properly I wouldn't
vaccinate and you can opt out everybody
can sign that up down for them but you
can never not supplement these longevity
cultures do supplement well there you
said they're third world culture they
are ill or they can't read how would
they know about supplementing well by
dumb luck they practice putting wood
ashes AKA plant minerals plant minerals
AKA wood ashes back into the garden and
that seems to have happened in every
culture around the world thousands of
years it survives yes that's the caveat
here and every continent on Earth these
surviving culture is all put wood ashes
into their Garden they are pregnant
women would eat wood ashes they had
these terrible Cravings they would eat
wood ashes during their pregnancy and
these are where the minerals come from
now what happened at three o'clock in
the afternoon Monday September 4th 1882
electricity you got it Thomas Edison
pulled the switch on the first
commercial electric generating plant on
Pearl Street in New York City and the
bluff overlooking the construction of
the Brooklyn Bridge every time I go to
New York I visit that site because that
is the thing that killed millions of
people because how many wood ashes how
many plant minerals do you have left
over how much powder you have left over
to put in your garden when you burn
electricity for fuel zero zero what
about propane or natural gas zero what
about solar energy zero oh my goodness
green can be bad unless you supplement
you got a supplement then you're not
throwing your life away based on the
throw of a dice every morning I mean why
would you do that to your kids why would
you do that to your loved ones why would
you do that to yourself I mean just
think about it if Steve Jobs if Linda
McCartney and Michael Jackson would have
supplemented with minerals Michael
Jackson Steve Jobs and Linda McCartney
all be still alive today oh fantastic
it's unfortunate that it didn't let me
ask you a question how much protein do
you recommend we eat per day well just
for maintenance a 150 pound person
requires 45 grams of pure protein well
to get 45 grams of pure protein like you
get in a laboratory setting you might
have to eat two pounds of protein you
know in this gross form as of beans and
meat and eggs and that kind of stuff to
get enough protein in the proper ratios
and so forth and so I like to err on the
side of excess I I for instance this
morning I had four Poached Eggs okay I
had two ounces of yogurt Cherry yogurt
and I had coffee with my chocolate added
to it so I had my Mocha Cafe the
flavonols the lower blood pressure and
give me some antioxidant points some
auric points oh I had nuts and I had
grapefruits okay plus all my supplements
so how many grams of protein would you
say that you had this before well in in
an egg and protein there's I think
there's 27 grams of protein per egg okay
so I got over 100 grams of protein which
is about double what they recommend okay
very high quality protein when you look
at the biological value of protein eggs
is a hundred red meat is 65 Dairy is 85
so it goes 100 for eggs 85 for dairy 65
for red meat you get down to in the 50s
52 to 55 for beans and it's in the 40s
42 to 45 for grain as a biological value
in other words that you can absorb them
as a human being and employ them into
rebuilding your own protein so if you
have a granny who's say 75 years old and
she's losing muscle mass because her
digestion isn't real good are you gonna
give her a vegan diet and give her beans
and protein you know beans and grain are
you going to give her eggs probably eggs
probably she's eating them anyway
that's why she's 75 right yeah she
should be getting egg protein because of
high biological value now here's the
thing that I I get from you know really
well-meaning people Dirk they say well
come on well like look at a cow you get
a thousand pound dairy cow like a whole
steam cow she weighs a thousand pounds
did she eat meat no did she eat eggs
well no uh did she eat fish or or
chicken no why do I need this she's
living on grass out there she could be a
thousand pounds well two things happen
there number one she has four stomachs
got a hundred million friends and that
one called a rumen those 100 million
friends are able to digest fiber and
turn it into amino acids fibers just a
string of carbon but there's little bugs
in there some of them animals some of
them plant material will take nitrogen
and put it onto the carbon chains and
turn them into amino acids and then
you're able to add sulfur to that in
your body and turn it into insulin okay
now cow does all that by just eating
grass and green plants growing on the
soil goats and do it by eating 2 eggs
and they browsy pigs and bushes and
things where the cows don't it's all the
same thing goats have four stomachs if
you look at all the kind of six I think
it sinks continents on earth um that
have animal life on it the most
universal form of animal life all over
the world is a room and there's four
stomach animal why in the old days in
the exploration days in the in the
settling days of America here in North
America do they use oxen to pull wagons
instead of horses because they eat grass
because they ate grass and they could
live on and do very well thank you on
the prairie grasses and didn't need you
didn't need to bring a separate wagon
Hall feed four horses or a single
stomach animal like you and me and they
can't eat the same thing as cattle can
and so they had to bring an extra wagon
full of grains for the horse and so
that's why they use oxen because oxygen
live off the land but horses you had to
carry their food with well that leads me
to another question I had for you is it
true that all foods have protein and
what's the difference between animal and
vegetable protein you gave us an example
of protein values but what's the
difference between the two types of
proteins and do all foods have protein
um all foods do not have protein okay
there's no protein in honey there's no
there's no but if you look at something
like an apple there's not much protein
in an apple unless you eat the seeds the
the Protein that's in an apple is in the
seed and when you look at a red
delicious apple what is the weight of
the seeds you know the two dozen seeds
that might be in that Apple it's not
even one percent of the weight of that
app they're very tiny little seeds to
make an apple there's extremely small
amounts of protein in that fruit uh the
more concentrated forms of protein are
in our grains and in seeds and also
beans legumes beans peas lentils things
of this nature also in peanuts which can
be problematic because of the aflatoxins
which is a byproduct of aspergillus
infestation you know fungus infestation
because liver Camp liver disease
liversarosis so that's a negative
they're getting protein from peanuts and
I hear that all the time because I
travel around this country I give 300
free lectures or I meet people you know
of every religion I meet people of who
have different food allergies I meet
people have different dietary beliefs
and so I see people who eat everything
you can think of and there's the
universal thing is the universal
shortages are minerals proteins
everybody can kind of get along they
your body has a great capacity to take
amino acids produced by just about
anything and turn it into protein and so
usually vegans have to eat quite a bit
during the day the great volumes of food
as well as eat maybe four or five six
seven meals a day they're constantly
grazing during the day if you want to
use that term in the same like thing
like a cow there's so little food value
in grass that cow is eating all day
constantly that's her job is just to eat
all day and hopefully get and there's a
lot of places on Earth where animals
don't grow there's no animal because
there's no nutrition in the soil so if
you want to grow animals there just
because there's grass the grass only
needs three minerals right counties and
so you're gonna have to supplement this
is one terrible study that I did in
kishan China in kishan China there's no
selenium in the soil in kishan China
there's no selenium in the soil they
have the highest rate of hypertrophy
cardamom with the heart attacks in kids
of anywhere in the world my wife and I
went there and over six week period we
did 1200 autopsies and kids below the
age of 10 who died of hypertrophic
cardiomatically heart disease was a slim
deficient they're all poor subsistence
Farmers they didn't have enough animals
to to provide cheese or meat for these
kids chickens couldn't live several many
of them and so they just lived on grain
and vegetables they could grow in the
garden they grew vegetables and grain
these kids would die of hypertrophic
Cardiology heart disease so we showed
them how to supplement with selenium in
a multiple and we wiped that disease out
in those communities but they have to
supplement fantastic that's an extreme
case but it's you know it's an
illustration what's happening on a lower
level in industrialized Nation because
for instance a omnivore somebody who
eats Dairy and meat and eggs and fish
and so forth they're going to get a
little bit of something especially if
they're eating animal products because
animals are supplemented right so
they're going to get a little bit of
something and you wonder why the the
people who when you look at the
long-lived people on Earth the top top
20 longevity cultures my wife and I
wrote a book called immortality where we
looked at that that was a question we
looked at who lives along us because we
were bombarded by people saying my
diet's the best my diet's the best my
does so we looked at these top 20
longevity cultures and we didn't pick
them the the National Geographic victim
we gleaned through 60 years of National
Geographic and they actually had special
issues on these top 20 longevity
cultures and I was always amazed that
they never put them all in one issue and
so we put all these cultures into one
issue
um one one magazine one giant book
actually called immortality and we
should we actually over 10 years through
the National Geographic through the
universities in the countries in which
these people live we looked at the soil
analyzes where these people lived we
looked at anthropology studies on them
what they ate and what their cultures
did and so forth how they got there this
is all in this book by the way
immortality shows you how these
illiterate countries these third world
cultures outlive us and are healthier
than us is by dumb luck by dumb luck
they happen to pick a place either they
were chased there by their enemies or
they picked this place because there's a
lot of game there to eat a lot of
animals to eat wild animals and by dumb
luck they have 60 or more minerals there
and so are putting their wood ashes in
the gardens or recycling those 60
minerals some of them have 70 some of
them have 80 minerals and they're
putting them all back in the gardens and
they're eating the plants that suck
these nutrients up but they're
supplementing with those minerals by
putting wood ashes in their Garden it's
an indirect supplementation although a
lot of them do put wood ashes in their
food they don't have flour to thicken
things with and so they will thicken a
lot of like stews and soups with wood
ashes so getting the minerals directly
that way and so they do supplement and
this is something we've missed ever
since we've given up wood is our common
Fuel and maybe people could do a better
job as vegans 100 years ago back if they
by dumb luck live in a place that had
enough minerals in the soil and they
were putting wood ashes in their garden
and consuming wood ashes they could as a
vegan survive and do very well but now
we don't do that so now they have to
supplement so that kind of takes me back
to the whole concept A lot of
vegetarians talk about is uh plant Foods
having amino acids let's talk a little
bit about amino acids and protein
complete protein versus income protein
let's talk about that a little well
again that's the Mantra that vegans talk
about they're talking about proteins
they're always talking about protein we
mix seeds and and beans and Grains to
guarantee the right amount of amino
acids and protein well amino acids are
the building blocks for protein amino
acids are building block for proteins
proteins are made up of combinations of
amino acids when you look at a protein
is a string of amino acids and when you
begin to digest them you don't just
break them down immediately into all
individual amino acids they're broken
down into Strings of amino acids short
strings from long strings or short
strings these are called polypeptide
okay if you absorb these polypeptides
which most people do and you have
nutritional deficiencies you can't fend
these things off you become allergic to
them your body recognizes them and wheat
or corn or potato or Pea or the
strawberries or whatever it might be
because you're not digesting these
things down to the individual amino
acids before you you absorb them and
this is a great great research project
where they actually show where you can
absorb digestive enzymes and these the
digestive enzymes they would take them
from your blood and still they worked as
an enzyme after taken from your blood
the digestion process didn't denature
the enzyme I found that very fascinating
people get hung up particularly vegans
and vegetarians of various types over
vegetarians oval lacto vegetarians oval
lacto piscopal vegetarians they get hung
up on the protein thing that's only one
of the 90 essential nutrients group you
need to to go and make sure you're
getting all 90 don't get fixated on the
protein and so is it a challenge though
even say for instance like myself a
person has been using all 90 Central
nutrients and using a protein supplement
is there still challenges for instance
cholesterol is that a challenge for a
vegan okay well protein you can you know
you can eat enough beans and Grains to
get protein now you've introduced a new
word here cholesterol now this is a
different story you have to appreciate
that 85 percent of the weight of every
cell on your body's cholesterol you have
steroid hormones such as testosterone
estrogen progesterone and and adrenal
hormones which are 85 or 90 by weight
cholesterol so your adrenal hormones
testosterone estrogen progesterone are
all steroid hormones and they're 85 to 9
by weight cholesterol so if you're not
eating cholesterol you cannot make
enough you cannot make enough to get all
the hormones you need you cannot make
enough rebuild and maintain your brain
85 percent no 75 75 of your brain weight
is the myel in the white matter of the
brain and 100 of the white matter of the
brain the mild of the brain the
insulation material the brain is
cholesterol and so if you think you're
going to get through life and live a
long healthful life and not be you know
have Dementia or depressed or mag
depression and so on um without either
supplementing with cholesterol you know
take a cholesterol Soft gel capsule like
we take fish oil capsules or eating eggs
and fat from meat you're living in la la
land you just can't do it you can't make
enough for your own needs so how much
cholesterol in comparison to how much
does the body make in comparison to what
you need not five percent the body makes
about five percent body makes about five
percent of the cholesterol that your
body needs if you're going to complete
cholesterol free diet you will not live
very long you just can't and
um if you I always tell people okay yeah
veganism was the optimal way to live and
I call veganism more of a political diet
as opposed to you know save the Earth
and don't eat animals you can feed 100
people for what you can feed one cow and
so I look at it as a political diet as
opposed to a nutritional diet unless
it's supplement you can do it
supplementary okay so I was comparing uh
we had talked about protein but I said
we can supplement with protein but the
cholesterol piece was that an issue
we're vegans yes okay and so the
cholesterol piece you have to supplement
cholesterol you have to eat cholesterol
every day again when you look at vegans
as a group you take an average lifespan
of vegans you take the average lifespan
of all peoples in the world and you take
an average lifespan of all vegans in the
world the vegans are not going to live
as long as the people who get animal
proteins because attached to animal
proteins is cholesterol I'm going to
start looking at the rates of emotional
problems with vegan depression mag
depression bipolar disease anxiety
attacks panic attacks I'm going to start
looking at adrenal exhaustion I'm going
to look at things like dementias
Alzheimer's disease infertility
miscarriages and a guarantee is much
higher in vegans as a group than it is
in meteors or at least people who eat
animal protein don't have to eat meat
you can eat eggs and fish and that kind
of thing if I had to pick one animal
protein I would pick eggs I would take
eggs because of the cholesterol
associated with it so we talked earlier
about the different types of vegetarians
in the U.S and so is there really any
difference because I know vegetarians
like to differentiate the ones that are
only eating fish think that they're
they're better off by avoiding the red
meat or avoiding the chicken is there
any real difference between the types of
protein including eggs when you're
talking about animal protein again when
you when you look at the biological
value this is well documented the U.S
department culture did this egg protein
100 Dairy protein is 85 red meat is 65.
beans and nuts and there's not much
protein in it it's mostly fat but not
cholesterol it's saturated fat beans and
nuts they're protein you're looking at
well 62 to 65 percent biological value
we're looking at grains it's down to 42
to 45 and so by mixing grains and nuts
and legumes you're better off because
you're raising that biological value up
for yourself and again it's it to me
it's a political statement more than a
nutritional a viable nutritional thing
because can you find me any colonies of
vegans Dirk where they weaned the baby
off the mother's breast milk and say a
year old two years old four years old
doesn't matter they wean the baby off
the mother's breast milk and then went
immediately to a vegan diet hundreds and
there's hundreds of kids happy giggly
kids running around well more I think
more what you're talking about in terms
of political and religious organizations
that become vegetarian or vegan because
of those reasons I don't know if any
other coaches otherwise but I was more
addressing sometimes people want to
think that their type of vegetarianism
for instance a lacto or a oval or Pesco
might think that it's better for them to
eat this way is significantly no
difference there's really no true again
eight protein and dairy protein are much
higher okay in the biological value
system but they're still eating animal
protein that's right yeah well and it's
still and and the reason I bring that up
is because typically people are so
afraid of cholesterol and no matter what
animal protein you're eating you're
getting cholesterol and so uh the value
you're saying egg is the best and then I
think it was uh chicken was before or
was was better than than red meat and so
forth and so on but I was just trying to
make a point in terms of uh you're still
getting Pro you're still eating animal
protein you're still eating cholesterol
and there are some values that are
higher in some of the proteins but
you're still eating animal protein so
you're you're not really a vegetarian in
other words yeah your omnivore you're a
person that eats animal and vegetables
yeah and so people who are not vegans
are really omnivores as opposed to
vegetarian absolutely okay let's move on
let's talk a little bit about energy
from a meat Source versus a vegetable
Source what's the difference there well
depending on what vegetable if you're
getting energy from lettuce you have to
work real hard to get if you get energy
from a potato
it costs you four times more in terms of
B vitamins than it does if you're
getting energy from meat red meat
because protein and fats are cheaper to
burn in terms of cofact as opposed to
carbohydrates carbohydrates are very
expensive to burn from terms of cofact
and so the worst thing we do in the
world Dirk is when you have these
famines you have these disasters around
the world natural disasters and famines
we think grain we send rice right rice
we send we send them white rice and
we're sending them plane loads and
boatloads and truckloads of white rice
and then they all die they all get berry
berry and they all get pellegra and they
all die congestive heart failure and
quashiorkor and all this kind of stuff
we'd be much better off to give them the
90 essential nutrients and a protein bar
and with bags of rice and again this is
all from advice being given to them by
Consulting doctors to the UN and to
governments all over the world people's
diet is primarily eating rice so let's
send them rice no they're eating chicken
eggs they're eating fish and they're
eating monkeys that they catch they're
eating you know their birds and they're
eating goat meat and cheese and milk and
everything you know even the Maasai they
live on cattle blood and milk and you
know you look at them and man they're
seven foot tall and they're very healthy
people and they live on milk and blood
and the secret though is they live in
places that have lots of minerals in the
soil and so the sweet potatoes and
things like that that they do eat the
POI and stuff that they
um are grown and soil that they're
putting their wood ashes back in there
they happen to live in places that have
lots of minerals and so it's it's more
than the superficial look and people
tend to not having the other knowledge
they don't know what questions to ask so
they say they visit there and they say
well these people are I mean they're
living on Rice you look at the Chinese
they're living on Rice well yeah but the
Chinese eat more animal protein per
person I think there's a book out called
The China Study and he said everybody in
China is a vegetarian of some type or
vegan well the only vegans and
vegetarians in China are American
visitors who are vegans well what about
Buddhists there are a lot of Buddhists
that are vegetarians also ah they're
vegetarians they're not vegans they will
drink milk and cheese and stuff okay
yeah so they'll do that so they're lacto
oval philosophy as opposed to being
vegan um and I remember back in the 60s
and 70s when uh athletes for instance or
on a high protein diet and then late 70s
and 80s moved to a high carb diet that
philosophy who's better off doing that
in the Long Haul the ones who are eating
a high protein diet or better often the
ones that ate a high carb diet remember
carbohydrates are more expensive in
terms of cofactors needed to get the
energy extracted from as opposed to
protein and when you look at some of the
crazy things professional athletes do
you know jump in the stands and beat up
paying customers and
they do crazy things they can't control
themselves and that's because they lose
these nutrients so fast because they've
carved up they carve up carb up carb up
the night before that was actually
invented by the wife of a Canadian his
name is Brian Maxwell he had Run 100
marathons he had 14 gold medals running
the marathon and his wife invented the
the power bar and went for the carbs and
she invented the the carb up the night
before and that way you had more energy
to run your race because they were
looking at the glycogen the animal
starch stored in your liver and muscles
and so forth and
um it was just one of those terrible
things they created because what happens
is when you carve up you're gonna have
energy for a while and then you crash
then you go into the state of depression
you go into a state of depression after
a while because your blood sugar is
dropping like a rock and this doesn't
happen when you eat protein because when
you have protein mixed with fat it
stabilizes your blood sugar and now
they've gone back to eating you know a
steak the night before and eggs for
breakfast before a big event whether
it's football or basketball or soccer or
run yeah I was a college basketball
player and I remember doing those mid
70s mid to late 70s we would eat steak
and eggs for pre-game meals and that was
pretty much the standard bad thing and
you'd stabilize your blood sugar and
you'd have enough nutrients to to
perform at a very high heaven the ones
who still practice carving up the night
before will crash somewhere in the
middle of the game okay well let's talk
a little bit about some of the positive
is about being a vegetarian uh for
instance the high antioxidant levels
which will increase your immune system
high fiber high water and even the 1970s
work done by Dr Dean ornish in terms of
clearing the arteries of some of his
patients using a vegetarian diet let's
try us some of the positives I guess and
to what degree they are positive for
sure um there are positives to vegan
diet but again you can't let those
positives blind you thank you blind you
to ignoring the negatives right yeah
what you want to do is get the positives
from a vegan diet and supplement and
make up the deficiencies the negatives
and you're fine and um you know I find
people like yourself who've been a vegan
for at least 20 years that I know of and
you're extremely well and you do your
Martial Arts your martial arts master
and I'm so very proud of you that you
supplement heavily um and you're an
example of what a vegan can be you're as
fit and tough physically as a vegan can
be and you've been very faithful to a
vegan diet I know this I've known you
for 15 years but you supplement properly
and you make up the deficiencies and so
whatever you get from your food is value
added now one of the things we have
learned about eating more vegetables and
fruits and things of that nature is that
the antioxidants will help fend off
certain diseases you can reduce your
risk of cardiovascular disease you can
reduce your risk of the benches you can
reduce your risk of cataracts you can
reduce your risk of cancer by getting
your orac points your antioxidant points
above a hundred thousand orac points a
day and orac points is an acronym that
was coined by the US Department of
Agriculture called oxygen radical
absorption capacity it's a measurement
of how many free radicals are actually
neutralized by the antioxidants in the
food and of course antioxidants come in
many forms let's just look at the one
that's produced by the body the most
potent one produced by the body is
called glutathione this is one of the
most potent antioxidants out there but
if you don't have enough selenium one of
the things that happens is one molecule
of glutathione will knock off one
molecule of a free radical and it's done
generous more if you're supplementing
with selenium in proper amounts that
selenium will recycle that one molecule
of glutathione so it might work against
one molecule of glutathione in the
presence of sicilium might knock off a
thousand
molecules of a free radical wow that's
amazing yeah and so you can't just think
in terms of the antioxid you get either
from the food or that's produced by your
body when you're eating that food and so
you do have to bring in all the support
cofactors to guarantee it's all going to
work properly so auric points is a way
of measuring that and of course
um one of the things we know result in
anti-aging effects are the antioxidants
you find in dark berries including
grapes black grapes purple and blue
grapes have more antioxidants than green
grapes you look at something as simple
as Resveratrol which is the stuff that
is given credit for the French Living 10
years longer than us they say well it's
the French paradox they live 10 years
longer than those because they wean
their babies off of breast milk under
wine they don't even drink water right
and Resveratrol so I like to take in the
equivalent of about 900 glasses of red
wine a day in terms of Resveratrol
supplementation and so I'm getting the
antioxidant power of 900 glasses of red
wine a day as opposed to drinking 900
eyes of red wine of course you wouldn't
get that far he'd be unconscious of all
the alcohol but my understanding too is
uh even even eating a very good
vegetarian diet I understand one serving
of a fruit or vegetable will only give
you about 600 auric points compared to a
supplement program where you can take as
you said anywhere from 50 to 100 000
very easily per day yes so the challenge
is even if you are a super duper
vegetarian and you ate uh 20 servings of
fruits and vegetables per day which most
people won't do you would never get past
ten thousand twelve thousand auric
points yes and that's sufficient to help
fight off disease you're exactly right
and of course you've taken what would
you say 200 servings of fruits no no I
said 20. yeah you're going to get
screaming diarrhea with all that fiber
and fruits and vegetables right and so I
like dark chocolate so we have a lot of
dark chocolate products and dark
chocolate is a wonderful way to get orac
points and you can take a good quality
dark chocolate liquid that has three
thousand Oak points per ounce we have a
piece of chocolate the size of a pad of
butter you take two of those little
pieces of dark chocolate that
um have or the size of a pad of butter
have the amount of antioxidants in it
that you get in 25 servings of fruits
and vegetables it'll give you 33 000
auric points eat two pieces of this
chocolate and it's vegetarian friendly
oh it is it's vegan it's vegan friendly
okay it's vegan friendly plus it has the
Flavin oils to help lower blood pressure
it's just they're wonderful things and
of course all vegans should be using are
dark chocolate because you can you could
take I take six pieces a day so I'm
getting over a hundred thousand auric
points a day and so whatever you get
from your food is value added now you
got it that that's the secret to making
this work whether you're a vegan a
vegetarian whether you're an oval lacto
vegetarian whether you're a meat eater
whether you're a meat and potatoes kind
of guy if you supplement you're leveling
the playing field so no matter what your
dietary choices are whatever value you
get from your food is value add you know
you look at a medical doctor who gets
less than 30 minutes of nutritional
training in 14 years of medical school
and residency an internship these guys
say well eat lots of variety and put
four different colors on your plate
that's insane when we spent 100 billion
dollars tripling the lifespan of dogs
eliminating 900 different diseases and
still play humans by making sure they
had all the nutrients in their food yeah
and the science is there and too often I
find in Natural Health that people will
approach me and say uh what'd you get
that from I don't believe it my doctor
never told me that well
their science is there you just haven't
read it and I always tell people also
you don't ride in a horse and buggy
anymore you drive a car I personally
don't wash my dishes by hand I put in a
dishwasher I mean if the science is
there use it and certainly the science
is there that nutritional
supplementation is so important and it's
such a struggle to get people to
understand that well all you have to do
is look at the lifespan of a doctor even
a vegan doctor the average lifespan is
56. why would you go to a group of guys
and gals whose average lifespan is 56 to
learn how to live be 100 in health away
they're not the go-to people as one of
my colleagues Dr Glidden always says God
bless her little hearts she's loving the
pieces but it should be a felony for
them to give advice when it comes to
nutrition they just their patients in
this service whenever they give them
advice about nutrition Let's uh let's
talk a little bit about some of the
negatives about vegetarianism for
instance those that have a high starch
high carb diet talk a little bit about
B12 deficiency and also like to discuss
some of the conditions that may arise
from pregnant women sure children okay
young teens all of those sort of things
let's start out on the front end here
let's start out with conception most of
the infertility problems that occur in
the world are caused by malnutrition and
I see a lot of people many of whom are
vegans who are infertile they just can't
get pregnant how do I get pregnant well
how many aging well not I'm a vegan well
there you go and so I said well I want
you to eat you know say 130 to 150 pound
woman I say I want to eat four eggs
every day I can't do that well you're
not gonna get pregnant oh you ever have
miscuits we have had four miscules that
means you're not it's Cheryl because you
can get pregnant you just can't hold a
pregnancy what are you supplement well
I'm a purist I just eat very well and I
get everything I need for my food well
no let's say you have a pregnancy in an
unsupplemented vegan the odds of you
having a baby that has some biochemical
or physical problems can be very high
cleft palate spina bifida neural tube
defects uh things like heart defects of
all kind a cerebral palsy Down syndrome
is very high cystic fibrosis mustard
dystrophy what I find is dirt and I work
with large colonies of certain cultures
that you know as much as there 30 to 50
percent of the births in those cultures
are cystic fibrosis the men died average
age of 62. with cardiomyopathy heart
disease all which is a slame deficiency
and so it's imperative when you know
these things in a community and not to
supplement just keep going to fertility
clinics hoping that this pregnancy be
the good one I'm paying thousands 25 000
for in vitro fertilization artificial
insemination and they're getting
pregnant naturally sexual intercourse
they just can't hold the pregnancy
because they don't have enough nutrition
to hold the pregnancy so I get more
women pregnant than any other man in
history I get about 25
000. I mean I the only one that I can't
keep up with is the history of Solomon
right he had 300 wives but I get about
25 000 women pregnant every year but
it's always from nutrition regulating
what they eat eliminating gluten adding
the 90 essential nutrients and then you
can eat whatever diet you want so what
about some of the deficiency conditions
like B12 iron deficiency anemia tell me
a little bit about that well these are
very common in people who are vegans
again both of those are nutrient
deficiencies right right
um and vitamin B12 is sort of a weird
vitamin and then it has a mineral
attached to it Cobalt okay and so when
you're deficient in B12 several things
can be happening number one you might
supplement with B12 and still be
deficient B12 if you don't have enough
stomach acid well how much salt do you
well none my doctor told me to cut back
on my cell so I just get enough for my
food really and you have a B12
deficiency well yeah so I have to take
B12 shot because I've tried salientation
won't work well that's because you're
not making enough stomach acid because
you require salt sodium chloride to make
stomach and so even if you supplement
with B12 and you're not making stomach
acid you can't absorb it because there's
a factor produced by the stomach called
intrinsic factor I guess the whole name
is Castle's intrinsic factor and it
binds with Von B12 in the presence of
stomach acid to be absorbed minerals
can't particularly iron can't since you
brought that up iron specifically has to
be absorbed in an acid environment if
you're drinking and I sell alcohol I
love alcohol but not during meals
because it neutralizes your stomach acid
and you won't be able to absorb
nutrients efficiently I see an enormous
number of people who are very very ill
with maybe 20 different diseases because
it can't absorb nutrients they're
drinking structured alkaline water with
meal so we have all kinds of problems
going on here that affect what goes on
in your stomach and even if you
supplement you could be deficient in
these things so iron is very tricky B12
is very tricky digesting proteins is
very tricky even if you're eating good
protein regardless of the source and
you're not making stomach acid then
pepsin the enzyme produced by the
stomach to digest protein down into the
amino acids which are then easily
absorbed and don't cause allergies
you'll wind up absorbing polypeptides
because you don't have enough stomach
acid for the pepsin to work properly I
find it interesting people always want
to say well cooking and microwaves
destroys the enzymes of my food well you
don't need enzymes in your food because
you produce all the enzymes you need if
you're getting a perfect diet oh that's
a great lead-in dot live food is a raw
foodist concept because too often
they're purest in their philosophy that
I'm not going to cook anything I'm not
going to raise the temperature above 117
degrees I'm going to get all the enzymes
and get all these great things and you
just share with us the body will make
enzymes if you're healthy and another
point that I want to make on that same
note those people are typically very
health conscious people like most
vegetarians they're trying to be healthy
but unfortunately they only have bits
and pieces of information they don't
have enough information to complete the
circle
they're they're in trouble unfortunately
exactly right and it's the pieces that
are left out that cause the problem cook
improperly when you eat improperly when
you supplement improperly you're going
to have problems and because vegans tend
to be very strict and and you know
there's breathitarians and there's raw
foodists and and so forth and most
people can't handle raw food diet
because there are phytates and raw
vegetables and Grains whole grains
phytates are the things that make a
carrot pop when you break it in half it
snaps if I taste or what makes whole or
the brand on wheat Hard and shiny um
it's the thing that makes the seeds on
the PODS of a pea snap when you when you
break it and these phytates bind onto
your dietary minerals into an indigen
indigestible unabsorbable compound which
goes out the other end in the toilet
they're going to even be very well and
the more raw foods you eat the more
you're in danger from phytates again in
chapter 11 of that book rare has been
cures I have a whole big section in that
chapter 11 on phytates and the hazard of
eating raw foods uh constantly with
breakfast lunch and dinner you're going
to be in trouble especially if you don't
supplement I think they most of the raw
Foodies are typically marinating their
foods and so they're not actually eating
it in its raw it's I guess if you is
that if that's a word we're always state
they're doing some sort of marinating
and some and eliminating that pop or
snap that you're talking about but the
enzyme piece is not factual is it dot no
you don't need enzymes from your food
you make all the ends of Digestive and
absorption enzymes you need to make all
this in fact that's what DNA and RNA do
is they make enzymes because we are
enzyme beings you can't use oxygen
without enzymes you can't use food
without enzymes you can't create energy
or burn energy without enzyme and so
you've been provided with all that you
need in your body you don't need to be
eating it but you do need to eat the raw
materials and the cofactor is necessary
for those enzymes to work okay well let
me ask you one more thing
um one of the I guess uh prideful things
that vegetarians talk about is having a
low-fat diet what's the challenge with
having a low-fat diet diet
vegetarians okay there's two problems
with a low-fat diet number one we are a
fat eating organism human beings are we
require fat in fact as much as 60 to 70
percent of your calories should come
from fat you know medical doctors say
that less than 30 they want you down 26
24 of your calories coming from fat
really we should be having 60 to 70
percent of your calories coming from fat
number one the stabilize your blood
sugar
and you don't get obese when you eat fat
when you think about that when they
fatten cattle for Ruth Chris's
Steakhouse to make them Prime Beef right
you go to the Hilton in New York City
and you want a Prime Steak I mean you
want two inches of fat on you want all
that beautiful marbling in the middle
and so tender you can cut it with a fork
do they feed those cattle fat or whole
grains whole grain oink
the reason why we're the number one
obese nation in the world is because
we've been told to eat whole grains now
eating whole grains in the absence of
minerals you will get fat you will
develop diabetes and so that's very
problematic whole fat is good for you
chicken fat not fried roasted raw baked
is good that's for the French you think
that a five-star French chef is going to
bake a croissant for the president of
France using canola oil and margarine oh
you can use eggs and cream and butter
and lard absolutely and they live 10
years longer than us all right also you
have the essential fatty acids right you
need Omega-3s sixes and nines but you're
fats whether it's plant fats or animal
fats some sources of these fats like
plant have maybe eight percent some oils
have only eight percent essential fatty
acids like olive oil is nice eight to
twelve percent
Omega-3s you look at flaxseed all 78 you
look at forage a board gel is very high
primrose oil and primrose oil is very
high of 78 but also when you look at
fish oil you look at very high seminal
78 omega-3 so there's certain plant oils
that are the same as fish oils but
there's certain plants that are very
very low and you couldn't eat enough to
get what you need we use fat very
efficiently for energy it doesn't cost
you a lot of cofactors so it's cheaper
to burn fat for fuel in terms of
cofactors than it is to burn
carbohydrates fat is very important to
human beings we eat we should be eating
60 to 70 percent of our calories coming
from fat and by chance then you're going
to get more of the essential fatty acids
but depending on what the animal ate for
instance if you eat a deer and eat the
fat from the deer or eat the fat from
chicken has been fed beans a lot of
beans and they're done they're going to
have more Omega-3s in it than if they're
just fed wheat only okay and and
um you need fat to again for energy we
need it to make our brain means and we
need the cholesterol that's in fat to
make steroid hormones testosterone
estrogen progesterone adrenal hormones
so people who are on a strict fat free
diet are not going to make okay and last
part that I like to discuss with you doc
many times vegetarians will pose certain
questions about meat and why we
shouldn't eat it for instance there are
pharmaceutical drugs and meat
antibiotics hormones pesticide residue
then talk they also talk about processed
Meats the dangers of cancer carcinogenic
effect of processed Meats parasites
bacteria high levels of adrenal hormones
and animal flesh let's talk about that a
little bit the the bad part that
vegetarians talk about in terms of meat
eating well certainly they're quite
correct I give them they're quite
correct when it comes to processed Meats
with nitrates and nitrites and it does
increase your risk of cancer increase
your risk of cardiovascular disease
particularly arterial sclerosis
anthosclerosis because elevated blood
cholesterol interglycerides do not cause
coronary our disease or any vascular
disease elevated blood cholesterol
articulous rides do not cause stroke
or high blood pressure or cardiovascular
disease or plug any of the arteries
Coronas thrombosis pulmonary emulators
and knee veins thrombosis it has nothing
to the cholesterol and
um it has nothing to do with
triglycerides it has everything to do
with eating things like processed Meats
with nitrates and nitrites eating fried
foods even eating stir-fried foods of
organically grown vegetables with extra
extra virgin virgin olive oil that's why
in 1971 when I did did that study
comparing the coronary arteries
blockages from vegans during meat eaters
the vegans had the worst plugged
arteries and
um the the thing you have to appreciate
from again the fat and the cholesterol
is that these are essential nutrients
and we must have them you have to get
them some way you can't make enough high
fat diets are useful for us we for
instance I can take people with the
Parkinson's disease and give them the 90
essential nutrients and a couple of what
we call our secret sauces and give them
12 to 15 eggs a day and I can I can
eliminate all Parkinson's symptoms in
three months people who have dementia
been diagnosed with Alzheimer's Disease
by four very well respected neurologist
and including the head of the Department
of Neurology to medical school diagnosed
this guy with Alzheimer's disease in one
week's time they declared him cured on
my program that's great because he had
to eat 12 eggs a day right because it
was replacing his brain plus the 90
essential nutrients and I do this
literally thousands of times a year
fixing people with these neurological
problems adrenal exhaustion is a
cholesterol deficiency disease is a fat
deficiency disease and I I know I see so
many people with adrenal exhaustion when
you go to these health fairs and trade
shows people who try to eat right
they're doing their best or their
heart's in the right place or trying to
eat right I have no disrespect for them
from that place but and I always tell
them if you want to be a vegan you can
be a successful vegan like my good
friend here Dirk twine if you just
supplement properly you can do it and so
if being a vegan is that important to
you you need to supplement do it
correctly and you'll you'll be fine but
if you don't supplement your your every
morning you're waking up playing that
game throwing those Dice and if he you
know Snake Eyes comes up absolutely so
basically doc the the point that I tried
to make initially was the vegan is the
one that is in the greatest danger
that's correct the other forms of
vegetarianism you're getting a lot that
the body needs peace that the vegan is
missing is particularly the cholesterol
piece and the fat piece and the minerals
and the mineral piece but all all types
need the 90 Central nutrients the 60
minerals the 16 vitamins the 12 amino
acids The Three fatty acids everybody
needs that every living breathing
walking human being and all vertebrates
hummingbirds elephants snakes or fish
all need it okay and so with the
essential nutrients the other types
other than the vegan type they're in
very good condition if it gets shape if
they're supplemented with all 90s
all 90 essential nutrients they're in
good shape but the vegan even with
supplementation there's some challenges
that we have to be aware of that's right
so it's very important that we know this
and understand this and I and for me
personally I became a vegan as I
searched for healthy eating ways I
didn't become a vegan for any other
reason other than seeking good health
and so as we learn more we should do
more and so I think it's very important
and I wanted to share that information I
want to thank you again doc because as I
said I've been a vegan for almost 20
years yeah I feel compelled to share
this information with other others so
that they can be healthy and live a long
healthy life and and I really appreciate
all the work that you've done and you're
far from being a vegetarian and sharing
this information so that the vegetarian
community and the uh and vegetarian
family can can live long healthy lives
all Americans can live long healthy
lives all people of the world with this
information can live long healthy lives
you're exactly right now there's no
reason why everybody can't live to be
well beyond a hundred a human being has
a capacity to live long well beyond a
hundred the fact that we don't has
nothing to do with genetics it has to do
with nutritional deficiencies I always
tell people if you're not prepared to
supplement properly what you're saying
is there's too much bother for you to
take supplements and kind of understand
why you need to take them and pass that
on your children it's it's more
important to just forget that stuff
because it's too much problem for you to
deal with it than having 50 more years
with your grandkids because if you
assemble them properly you're going to
get 50 more years of their grandkids is
it and to me that's worth everything I
pluck my eyes out and cut my arms off
for 50 more years of my grandkids right
and so just changing my dad a little bit
and supplementing that's a small price
to pay for 50 more years with their
grandkids absolutely thank you very much
God bless your dirt keep up the great
thank you this CD is not intended to
diagnose describe or treat any diseases
it is your responsibility to consult
your personal health care practitioner
prior to beginning any type of health
and wellness program also ask the person
that gave you this CD for more
information about Dr Wallach and his
nutritional products
thank you